i
[Música]
en eeuu con múltiples arrestos o por
tanto cumplió cien noches de protestas
anti racismo la ola contra la brutalidad
policial atraviesa el país y la última
ciudad en estallar fue rochester tras
conocerse en vídeo el caso de daniel
plus un hombre afro con problemas
mentales que murió asfixiado por la
policía de nueva york
la organización mundial de la salud
declaró que no avalarán ninguna vacuna
contra el cob y 19 hasta que se
demuestre que es segura el organismo
también invitó a la comunidad
internacional a evitar el nacionalismo
de una posible cura se estima que la
vacunación podría iniciar a mediados del
y el fiscal general de el salvador
anunció una investigación por
acusaciones contra el presidente en allí
bukele que estaría negociando con
miembros de la pandilla mara salvatrucha
el número de homicidios bajo 56 por
ciento y la organización international
crisis group dijo que podría deberse a
un entendimiento informal con el
gobierno
estamos en france 24 para presentar las
noticias más importantes de américa
latina y del mundo mi nombre es ángela
gómez buenos dias iniciamos en eeuu
portland oregon llegó a las 100 noches
de manifestaciones contra el racismo y
la brutalidad policial un pedido que se
replica en todo el país impulsado por la
muerte a manos de un policía de georg
floyd en mayo las autoridades de
portantes declararon que se estaba
haciendo una asamblea ilegal después de
que los manifestantes marcharon hasta un
edificio de la policía rodeado de
agentes hacia la medianoche hubo
arrestos y el uso de gases lacrimógenos
las movilizaciones también suceden en
rochester en el estado de nueva york en
rechazo al fallecimiento del marzo
pasado de daniel fruit un hombre
afroamericano de 41 años asfixiado con
una bolsa que la policía le puso en la
cabeza para evitar que mordiera o
escupiera a los agentes pese a las
denuncias el sindicato de la policía
defiende que siguió el protocolo
es esta bolsa de malla la que se cree
que mató a daniel brühl como se ven en
las imágenes de la cámara de policía los
oficiales colocaron la llamada capucha
anti escupitajo mientras tenía una
crisis psicológica y de drogas inducida
que oficiaría a proud minutos más tarde
para el sindicato de policía de
rochester nueva york
los oficiales no hicieron nada malo esta
noche del 23 de marzo y tenían que hacer
exactamente lo que hicieron
tenían deben entender las frustraciones
de nuestra parte también cuando tenemos
que hacer los procedimientos y
protocolos que tenemos no hay opción de
cambiarlos en absoluto amnistía
internacional ha condenado el uso de
capuchas anti escupitajo por parte de la
policía diciendo que las bolsas pueden
ser peligrosas cuando se usan en
personas en peligro para los
manifestantes de rochester la muerte de
plutón en primer plano la cuestión de
cómo la policía se enfrenta y trata las
emergencias de salud mental y de drogas
los manifestantes dicen que los
trabajadores de la salud y no los
oficiales armados son necesarios en
tales casos y que brut es otro ejemplo
desgarrador del
brutalidad policial que debe detenerse
[Música]
en este punto se siente como si no
estuvieran escuchando porque sigue
sucediendo una y otra vez así que espero
que con estas protestas cuanto más
fuerte nos pongamos a alguien más nos
escuchará y con suerte se producirá un
cambio los manifestantes continúan
coreando sus nombres vidas de
afroamericanos a cortadas a manos de
oficiales de la policía ya sea brión a
taylor que fue asesinada en su casa
george's floyd cuyos últimos momentos en
un estrangulamiento policial provocaron
masivas manifestaciones raciales en eeuu
y en todo el mundo
hoy echo play gravemente herido tras
recibir un disparo en la espalda un
espectáculo de violencia policial que ha
sumergido a muchos estadounidenses en
una discusión sobre la demanda de
cambios en el tratamiento policial hacia
los afroamericanos en eeuu
la ms llamó a la comunidad internacional
de evitar el nacionalismo de una vacuna
además del organismo no respaldará
ninguna cura a menos que se demuestre
que es segura y espera que la aplicación
de anticuerpos inicie a mediados de 2021
esto mientras rusia defiende la eficacia
de su vacuna experimental y en eeuu
donald trump o confía en que la suya
esté lista antes de noviembre informa
juan pupiales el mundo vive una nueva
suerte de carrera espacial ya no se
busca alcanzar la luna sino obtener una
vacuna contra el cob
19 es una guerra de laboratorio sobre la
que la organización mundial de la salud
pide serenidad using vaccines as global
usar las vacunas como bien público está
en el interior de cada uno de los países
el nacionalismo de la vacuna prolongará
a la pandemia no la hará más cosas lado
ms advierte que no van a respaldar la
vacuna hasta que se demuestre que es
segura y que esa vacuna a nuestra lista
para una distribución masiva hasta
mediados del próximo año pero desde la
casa blanca hay otro mensaje
acabo de hablar con el director de facer
gran tipo anunciaron que esperan tener
resultados de sus pruebas muy pronto el
próximo mes pero muy pronto
permaneceremos en el camino para
distribuir la vacuna antes de fin de año
e incluso antes del primero de noviembre
antes del primero de noviembre es decir
antes de las elecciones y si las
cuestiones de tiempo entonces rusia
tiene la delantera su ministro de
defensa aprobó la vacuna experimental de
moscú la sputnik 5g este viernes fue
elogiada por la revista lancet tras ser
probada en 76 personas es un medicamento
que ha demostrado una respuesta inmune
con anticuerpos pero eso no es
suficiente según algunos expertos
hay que perder el tiempo posterior a que
una inyecta un líquido que contiene ese
virus atenuado o modificado para ver si
primero genera los anticuerpos segundo
si esos anticuerpos se mantienen en el
tiempo por lo mínimo de tiempo ocho
meses aunque hay entre 6 y 9 candidatas
en fases avanzadas la única certeza
según la ong es que cuando estén listas
tendrán que aplicarse con prioridad es
esa parece ser otra batalla en el
horizonte
en ecuador se volvieron comunes las
renuncias y las licencias del personal
médico en el sector público según el
instituto ecuatoriano del seguro social
los profesionales que enfrentan el hobby
19 tienen miedo al contagio y padecen
estrés porque se sienten desprotegidos
por el ministerio de la salud y porque
sus pagos están atrasados la historia
desde gustavo ortega a nuestro
corresponsal en quito
[Música]
es la imagen que se repite los centros
de salud pública del ecuador
familiares reclamando información de sus
pacientes
mientras que adentro se lucha una
batalla silenciosa
dos mil médicos del sector público
renunciaron o se declararon vulnerables
según cifras el ejecutivo nacional
paul dirige este auditorio convertido en
hospital público temporal donde el
estrés se apoderó de sus pasillos cerca
del 40%
y desertaba o buscaba la manera de tener
un certificado médico para no para
justificar el no estar aquí
los médicos están cediendo la batalla
luego de seis meses de emergencia los
colegas están empezando a consultar en
aproximadamente un 50% adicional porque
temas por temas ligados a la depresión
es decir síntomas depresivos tristeza
vital profunda pérdida de placer por
realizar las cosas ideas de ruina culpa
y muerte por síntomas ansiosos es decir
sensación de pérdida de control
control que diego no puede darse el lujo
de perder en sus tiempos libres combate
el estrés intenta sacarle provecho a su
talento para no formar parte de la nueva
estadística y ya tenía que ver la
posibilidad de tal vez retirarme un
semestre del posgrado y justo hubo esta
oportunidad de empezar a trabajar en un
área como bic pues la tomé la tomé más
del hecho por ayuda a mi familia por el
hecho de yo mismo quererme superar un
día más para diego quien guarda lo
necesario
es el miedo por no formar parte de los
127 trabajadores de la salud fallecidos
a causa de la pandilla en ecuador'
el fiscal general del salvador de raúl
melara anunció que investigará denuncias
de supuestas negociaciones entre el
gobierno de najib bukele y la pandilla
mara salvatrucha los llamados encuentros
informales fueron denunciados por la
organización international crisis group
y tendrían relación con la reducción de
los homicidios que este año fue del 56%
y que busquen le presenta como su mayor
logro en un año de mandato además una
investigación periodística del medio
local 'el faro' habla de favores
electorales causa indignación y rabia
ver que toda la población está viendo
verdaderamente los resultados de este
plan control territorial y quiere
desmeritar algo que ha costado a medio
tiempo de estar más y comunicación sin
nada de nuestra familia la verdad no
sabemos nada de eso
pero nunca en la convivencia más las
tres fracciones convivimos bien
usted recuerde que también puedes
seguirnos en france24 punto com cuídese
mucho y que tenga una feliz mañana de
sábado
[Música]